>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Fenella France:
I'm Fenella France,
chief of Preservation Research
and Testing Division and I want
to welcome you to this series of
one of our talks presentations.
We are absolutely
delighted today to be able
to introduce Randy Silverman,
who is well known
to many of you.
Randy served as the head of
preservation at the University
of Utah Marriott
Library since 1993.
He teaches workshops on disaster
planning for the Western States
and Territories Preservation
Assistance Service WSTPAS
and is recognized for
his national disaster
recovery efforts.
He has 80 professional
publications
and has presented professional
lectures or workshops
in 30 states and 13
foreign countries,
we'll ask for a list later.
He was given the American
Library Association Banks Harris
Preservation award in 2013,
received a Fulbright
specialist award in 2014,
and was awarded the Utah
Academy of Sciences,
Arts and Letters Gardner prize
for outstanding academic
contributions in 2016.
When I spoke with Randy last
year and we were starting
to talk about some
collaborative research
and he mentioned this project.
And we were talking about you
know some of the challenges
with some of these
larger projects
and he very graciously
agreed to come
and talk with us about this.
So, his presentation today is
a mold outbreak in Tbilisi,
Georgia, technical and
interpersonal challenges
and please help me
welcome him today.
[ Applause ]
>> Randy Silverman:
It's all right,
it's only cords we're fine.
Hello everybody, hello at home.
I'm so glad that you're here.
This is a really wonderful
opportunity, so for the people
at home today I'm speaking
from the lovely Mary
Pickford Auditorium.
Do you all remember
Mary Pickford?
And I'd like to thank
Fenella France who's the chief
of Preservation Research and
Testing here at the Library
of Congress for inviting me
and for this opportunity
to speak today.
I'd like to thank Alberta Comer
who is my dean at the University
of Utah's Marriott
Library for her support
because that's why I'm here.
And I'd like to dedicate
this talk to my mom
who died last year while I was
in Georgia, so there's that.
And of course, my better
half, Eileen Hallett Stone,
who is maybe watching
from home, we don't know,
and to our colleagues on the
ground doing disaster recovery
in Puerto Rico after
hurricane Maria.
I'm pleased that the
earthquake yesterday
in Honduras did not
cause a tsunami,
which would have further
complicated things.
And for everybody who
has or will spend time
as Gary Frost puts it
in the disaster fields,
thank you very much
for your service.
I first met Zurab who's
the library director
at the University of Tbilisi
on a US State Department
familiarization tour in 2013.
He and other Georgian library
directors toured the University
of Utah's Marriott Library
and when I showed him our
conservation lab he asked me
questions about mold
and I didn't know then what
he was really talking about.
But two years later when
this picture appeared
in the New York Times captioned
zoo animals on the loose
in Tbilisi after
flooding I was concerned
and so I contacted
the library to find
out if the flood
had affected them.
And while the collection
was unharmed
by that flood this mold
problem was still going on
and it was still a big issue.
So, the Blue Shield of Georgia
identified grant possibilities
and along with the library's
conservation department
at the university wrote a
cultural heritage emergency
stabilization grant to the
Prince Claus Fund in Amsterdam.
And the first grant was
not successful, but a year
and a half later the
second one [audio cuts].
So, I arrived in Tbilisi
on January 27th, 2017,
which is like a year
ago for a 10-day visit
and my hosts were Menana
[phonetic] who is pictured
on your left and who is the
head of Blue Shield and Marie
who is the paper conservator
at Tbilisi State
University Library.
Georgia for I had weak
geography as a child,
so I'm always curious like
on a map falls under Russia
and is situated near
Turkey and Armenia.
And I mention for the
people viewing from Georgia
that those striped areas
are the territories
that were lost during the
2008 Russo Georgian war,
that war lasted five days,
and the occupation still
affects 20% of the country.
When I first arrived,
it had snowed in Tbilisi
which is unusual
for them and coming
from Florida I thought
it was great to see snow
on the palms, this is unusual.
I was also able to see some
of their wonderful
historic buildings
like this 12th century
Orthodox Church
and these 19th century
hot baths,
which is kind of
a wonderful thing.
And there were carts in the
streets selling colorful spices
and churchkhela which are
traditional homemade Georgian
candle-shaped candies.
It's a really great place,
you should go see it.
So, the main library at Tbilisi
State University was built
in 1987 and it was out
at the edge of town.
This is a part of the
city that was new in 1987
and it was anticipated to grow,
but the growth never
materialized after the collapse
of the Soviet Union
December of 1991.
So, there was a persistent
lack of maintenance money
and that's left this
30-year-old building which is
about 400,000 square
feet largely unheated
and very run down.
In this slide the yellow
parts are the rooms
where the rare books are
stored, the top one is
on the first floor belowground
and the other one is the
second floor above that,
but it's still belowground.
And there's actually another
room on the second floor sort
of toward the core of the
building, I'm pointing for those
of you at home, I don't
know if you can see that.
So, those rooms were used
for storing rare books
for a very long time and
they were the problem.
So, we suited up to
go see the rare books.
The young woman who's
holding the key was not amused
by our use of personal
protection equipment she thought
it was weird and was kind of
put out that it took us so long
to prepare to enter this space.
She's waiting tapping
her foot you know.
Notice that at the base
of the walls there's signs
of moisture damage, that
was prevalent throughout
the building.
So, I would constantly see signs
that there had been
water damage over time.
So, we entered this space and
it's kind of dark and mysterious
and inside we found 80,000
rare books and that's 80,000
in these multiple rooms,
that were stolen from Germany
by the retreating Soviet Army
at the end of World War II.
So, in the 1970's Germany
asked for the books back
and they were stored at
two places in Georgia
and the other library
gave their books back,
they were happy to do it.
However, the University
of Tbilisi's books
were badly molded.
And so, Germany really wanted
to help, so they offered
to come there and they reviewed
the problem several times
and finally said you
know it would be easier
to bring the books to
Germany and treat the problem
where we have a lot of
equipment and facilities.
And so, they ran with
that idea for a while,
but there was a glitch because
shipping cultural property
out of Georgia is against
the law, so then they had
to change the law
to be able to do
that even though the
books belonged to Germany.
And eventually, it just
took years and after
like a decade Germany said we
actually, we don't care anymore,
we relinquish our hold
on the books they're
yours, have a nice day.
So, they now legally belong
to Tbilisi State University
and they're in good shape
when you open the book.
You know they're rare
European imprints
and the paper quality looks
great, there's no problem
until you see the outside.
And the outside was coated
with a thick layer of mold
and the molds changed,
there was different types,
there's dark molds and
light molds and a kind
of patterny [phonetic] mold,
molds like you've never seen.
In fact, I was speaking
with people at the Centers
for Disease Control in the
US and they halfhearted,
it was half serious in their
jokes saying you know it's a
shame to destroy
such a rare example
of a mature mold
ecosystem and it was.
They were really interesting.
And in fact, so I'm
there in in January
and this is a largely
unheated building,
it was freezing cold everywhere
except for a few offices.
But I was surprised to see
that this ancient stand
of old growth mold was dry
and powdery to the touch
in some cases, you could
just like push it away.
So, it seemed to me
on first observation
that it's actually growing
and thriving in the summer
and hibernating in the winter
and I didn't know mold did that,
so that was interesting to see.
So, we started looking for
the source of the water
and that orange stripe
represents a 12-inch city
watermain that's running
underneath the street
and parallel to the library
that has been leaking
apparently for years.
And the university claims that
the city water department needs
to repair their leaking
pipe, that's how it's done
in Utah at home right.
But the city takes the position
that the pipe is running
through university property and
so it's the university's problem
and there's been a standoff.
So, the willingness
to ignore a problem
that was actually causing
standing water in the library
at some points made me realize
that the lack of resources was
so serious for everyone that
not dealing with problems
like this is what
you have to do,
so that's still taking some
adjustment I have to say.
So, we examined the
building from the basement
to the rooftop looking
for water sources.
Don't you love it I'm in a
basement with my suit on,
this is typical for
tourists right.
And we used a moisture meter,
which is a really great tool
for defining whether
or not there is water
active in the walls.
So, some of the damage
in the walls would not set
off the moisture meter,
it was just old damage as
opposed to actively being wet
and in some places, there
was active mold growing
which was you know
a little weird.
And interestingly,
what we were looking
for originally was the source
of water coming from the street,
from that you know because all
the mold damage seemed to be
in those rooms that were on
that side of the building except
for that other room
that I mentioned,
which is in the core
of the building.
And so, it seemed suspicious
that the water could reach
the middle of the building
without having a central source.
So, we checked inside the
plumbing chase for the building
which runs parallel to
the stairs, so going up
and the plumbing chase
walls were soaking wet.
So, the plumbing in
the middle of the core
of the building is
leaking, it's like 30 years
of not fixing the pipes right,
it's a bad problem at home,
it's a bad problem when you
have a big library like this.
So, the Georgian National
Center for Disease Control
and Public Health
sampled the air
and counted the colony forming
units in these Petri dishes,
they did lots of testing.
The primary fungi
were Aspergillus
and the bacteria was nocardia.
Their findings though indicated
that and this is a quote,
the number of colony
forming units
in the library does
not pose a health risk.
I was kind of surprised, in
the US we'd shut the building
down right, no question
shut it down.
And yet, this is kind of the
response that you might get
if there's actually not
a way to deal with this
and everybody agrees what
can we do, we can do nothing,
we have to accept this.
So, I kept running into things
that were a little peculiar
in my orientation, but
it was a little scary
because in fact the library
is the testing center
for the university, there
were about 2,000 people
in the building a day and
I talked to some people
and they got, they had
gotten sick or were sick
and they were worried.
So, I met with the
library's administration,
this is Zurab again
back in Georgia
and I expressed my concerns
about the health issues
and agreed to help diagnose
the problem, try and look
for the source of water
and to define a protocol
that would allow them to
recover the rare books
because in fact the books
looked pretty good except
for the outside coating of mold.
And so, Marie and Menana helped
assemble a team of local people
that included Lowry
[phonetic] who's here sketching
because he's the one of the
buildings original architects,
he was always sketching and
now retired, but he wanted
to be part of the project
because he still
loved the building
and it just it broke his heart
it had not been cared for,
which is pretty wonderful.
And Lasha [phonetic]
whose got his back
to us who's a really
wonderful man
and he's a preservation
architect.
So, we started thinking
about the problem and we met
for several days trying to work
out you know what an affordable,
underline affordable, culturally
appropriate solution would
look like.
So, here we see the back
of Menana's head and Lowry
and Lasha and in this picture,
we have Giorgi [phonetic]
who's the heating, ventilating
and air-conditioning engineer
who's joined us and members
of the preservation department.
I have to hurry now,
that was my mother.
Other people who contributed
to a proposed solution long
distance included Kirk Lively,
who's the director of
technical services at Belfor.
Bernard Mayer, whose Belfor's
major loss operations person
in Europe who actually
volunteered to come to Georgia
and set up the drying and
the air ventilation solution
for just his travel costs.
He was going to come on his
own time and just volunteer
to do that, which is
really extraordinary.
Allen Rogers at a company
called Zentox in Canada,
which is an air purification
company.
Ian Poole Corroventa, a supplier
of dehumidification
equipment in England.
Because there's a big
problem how are we going
to get this stuff to Georgia.
And Doctors Cox, Ganser
[phonetic] and Park
at the Centers for
Disease Control
and Prevention in
the United States.
So, we all agreed as Kirk Lively
put it that the building had
to be dried first to stop
the mold bloom, makes sense.
So, vacuuming mold off the
books and then returning them
to a humid environment only
provides a temporary solution
and will allow the mold
to continue thriving.
So, Lawry recommended we
dig an architectural gallery
on three sides of the building
and that's what the yellow
arrow is pointing to.
And a gallery which is
a term I didn't know is,
this is an example of a
gallery I found someplace else,
they're using these.
This is an architectural
gallery in this case designed
to allow people to see historic
foundations of a building
so you could use it
for that purpose.
The library's gallery
would be graded on top,
so it would get air ventilation
and people could walk over it.
Be bricked on one side so the,
you know, to keep the dirt
from caving in and
allow this airspace
where the airflow would dry
the walls of the building
and prevent moisture from
coming in direct contact
with the basement walls
and if it did it would dry
because of air circulation.
It seemed like a pretty
neat idea, we're talking
about digging a hole around the
building right, pretty simple.
So, we took that idea
and presented it to Nunu
who is the chancellor for
Tbilisi State University
in an hour-long meeting.
And we kept the proposal
as simple
and cost-effective as possible.
So, here I'm presenting
a PowerPoint summation
of our recommendations
and I'm using a laptop
so that was the most
straightforward way to do that.
And in in the room are
also Zurab and there's Nunu
in the background, Marie
and other administrators.
So, while I was there the
library people also asked me
to give a public lecture on
the causes of mold and ways
to mitigate those
kinds of problems.
And so, the talk
was well attended,
you kind of like
you guys showing
up that's really wonderful.
And it was a Saturday
afternoon and we were
in the other library, it turned
out there's another library
in the main campus in the
middle of Tbilisi which was neat
as a pin right, so
that was also a clue
that maybe this other
library wasn't loved
for some reason, I don't know.
So, I gave a talk about what I
think we know as a profession
about mold and if
you'll permit me I'd
like to share those
ideas with you.
Actually, it's the core of what
I want to talk about today,
it's the meaningful
part, the takeaway.
So, while nobody knows
for certain how many types
of mold there are, it's
estimated that there are
between 100,000 and 300,000
species of mold on earth along
with the ants and
the buzzards okay.
The fungi represent
approximately 3 1/2%
of all living species,
so it seems clear to me
that mold is not
an afterthought.
Common indoor mold species
include Cladosporium,
Penicillium, Alternaria
and Aspergillus,
they're here, they're around us.
What you may not know this and
this is an interesting thing
to consider, one cubic meter of
outdoor air may contain as many
as a million spores okay.
And a grown person at
rest inhales about two
and half gallons
of air per minute.
So, what that means is on
average people inhale close
to 600,000 spores per
hour all the time okay,
interesting right.
But inside a moldy building like
that it could be 10 times that,
so 600,000 is your minimal
daily dose per hour okay,
that's normal, a normal day.
Mycelium is a vegetative part of
the fungi consisting of a mass
of branching threadlike hyphae.
The white or transparent hyphae
may be minute forming a colony
that's too small to see
or the mycelium might
be extensive appearing
like very fine fluffy white
threads over the surface.
Mycelium is considered
a single organism.
Typically mold secrete
hydraulic enzymes mainly
from the hyphae tips to
degrade complex biopolymers,
biopolymers such as starch,
cellulose and lignin,
our stuff right into
simpler monomers
that can be absorbed by hyphae.
Molds play a vital role in
causing the decomposition
of organic matter
that enables recycling
of nutrients throughout the
ecosystems, it's good for us.
When mold is ready to reproduce
small treelike fruiting bodies
form on the ends of the hyphae.
The dusty texture of
many molds is caused
by the profuse production of
asexual spores called conidia
that grow on the
tree-shaped hyphae.
The mode of formation
and the shape
of these spores is
traditionally used as the method
for classifying molds.
These spores come in a variety
of colors making the fungus much
more obvious to the human eye
at this stage in its lifecycle.
So, we like it when it's pretty
or we don't really don't like it
when it's pretty, it depends.
When we think of
mold germinating
in dark warm damp humid
places we tend to forget
that mold also grows in
the refrigerator right.
So, the question is and this is
the question for you guys right,
how long will a jar
of applesauce stored
under Saran wrap be
good to eat right.
Three days, a week?
Do you have a teenager?
If your refrigerator is
working right it's probably fine
for a week right,
but if applesauce is forgotten
behind the other groceries
for three weeks there might
be a tipping point somewhere.
The deal is if food is sitting
around for some time it can
cause an activation trigger
for mold when the storage
environment is right.
Environmental factors
that affect mold growth
include the standard
environmental factors.
Temperature, a refrigerator
in good repair hovers
around 37 degrees Fahrenheit or
3 degrees Celsius for my folks
at Georgia, but cold,
it's cold but not frozen.
The relative humidity of
applesauce is very humid.
Light levels in the refrigerator
are nice and dark right
and airflow which is restricted
by the Saran wrap
may be an issue okay.
So, our Finnish colleagues Hukka
and Vitanen developed a model
that characterizes six
stages of mold growth.
Of these the first two stages
include no visible sign
of mold except under
magnification right,
it's among us but we
can't really see it.
That leads us to remember that
mold may be actively growing
around us, but we
are not aware of it.
So, if you allow me
to anthropomorphize
the question a little.
What is the tipping point
at which mold decides
that an open jar of applesauce
is fair game all right,
when will that occur?
And for that I think we
need to call in the experts.
So, I'm going to tap into Monty
Python who will try and answer
for us the age-old
question, how can you tell
when an object is really dead.
>> Here's one, nine pence.
>> I'm not dead.
>> What?
>> Nothing, here's
your nine pence.
>> I'm not dead.
>> Here, he says he's not dead.
>> Yes, he is.
>> I'm not.
>> He isn't.
>> Well, he will be
soon, he's very ill.
>> I'm getting better.
>> No, you're not, you'll
be stone dead in a moment.
>> Oh, I can't take him like
that, it's against regulations.
>> I don't want to
go in the cart.
>> Oh, don't be such a baby.
>> I can't take him.
>> I feel fine.
>> Oh, do us a favor.
>> I can't.
>> Well, can you hang
around a couple of minutes?
He won't be long.
>> Nah, I got to go
on to Robinson's
they've lost nine today.
>> Well, when is
your next round?
>> Thursday.
>> I think I'll go for a walk.
>> You're not fooling
anyone you know.
Look, isn't there
something you can do?
>> I feel happy, I feel happy.
>> Ah, thanks very much.
>> Not at all.
See you on Thursday.
>> Right.
[ Laughter ]
>> Randy Silverman: The earth
does not leave dead things lying
around for long.
Buzzards and ants and
mold all work to clean
up mother nature's dead to
recycle them back to carbon.
It's part of the complex balance
the governs our lovely blue
jewellike and very
hungry planet.
For mold the rules are
really quite simple,
if it's breathing it's not
dead and it's not food,
where there's breath
there's life.
Wind is just the
planet breathing
as far as mold is concerned.
So, we should remember it's when
things get out of equilibrium
that mold feels invited
to the feast.
So, let's look at
a couple examples.
This is Lascaux Cave some
drawings from Lascaux Cave
in southwestern France, we're
not in France now I'll clarify
that point, though you at
home may be I don't know.
So, the cave contains some
600 paintings believed
to be 17,300 years old.
It's among the most significant
cultural artifacts on earth
and was inscribed in UNESCO's
World Heritage list in 1979.
Lascaux Cave was discovered
by 18-year-old Marcel Ravidat
and three friends who were
trying to rescue their dog
who had fallen through a
foxhole in September of 1940.
You had to be a kid
to find those drawings
because they were nowhere
near the entrance of the cave
and they were hidden in complete
darkness right, teenagers.
Like most caves Lascaux was
perpetually cold and very humid
above 95% and it was
free of visible mold.
Wanting to share this important
find a large-scale earthwork was
begun in 1947.
And so, they redesigned
the cave's entrance
to permit visitor access.
This permanently
and irreversibly changed the
natural equilibrium inside the
cave and black mold was
first reported on the walls
in 1947 in that same year.
The cave opened to the
public July of 1948
and by 1955 Lascaux received
30,000 visitors per year.
By 1960, that was 100,000
people which works out to
about 1,800 visitors per day
at its peak and an average
of 70 people per hour right,
things were really
crowded there.
In 1950, they put a stairway
and a double access door in
and it was designed as
an airlock specifically,
that's indicated
by the blue arrow.
During the 1955 tourist season
the cave experienced abnormally
high levels of carbon dioxide,
condensation on the walls,
and high temperatures.
So, what would you do?
They put in an HVAC system
in 1958 and it was able
to maintain the cave's
temperature
at 57 degrees Fahrenheit which
is 14 degrees C and 95% Rh,
normal is 95% Rh right,
that's interesting right,
it doesn't mold all the
time just because it's wet.
Although this prevented
condensation
on the walls discrete green
spots however described
by the curator as green
disease were noted
in 1960 near the artwork
in the axial gallery.
By 1963, this mold
outbreak became denser
and extended to the
hall of bulls.
The cave was closed to
the public that year
and the committee convened
to study the problem.
Antibiotics and formalin
were used to kill the mold
on the floors and the walls,
including the painted
surfaces themselves.
That original HVAC system
failed in 1998 after 40 years
of service and it was replaced
by an improved hydrothermal
regulator in 1999.
This precipitated the active
mold event now referred
to as the crisis of 2001.
Here we see air sampling
being conducted
in Lascaux Caves axial gallery.
The mold species
determined to be responsible
for the outbreak was
identified as Fusarium Solani
and here we see visible signs
of the active mold growth
in the axial gallery in 2001.
So, treatment options were
explored for killing the mold
on the walls and paintings
during the crisis of 2001
and these included,
this is radical,
gassing Lascaux methyl bromide
raising the carbon levels
so the environment would
become lethal to the mold
and other biological measures.
Each of those ideas
was determined
to be too risky for the artwork.
In the end, quaternary ammonium
which is alkyl dimethyl
benzyl ammonium chloride,
which is a fungicide used
in the papermaking
industry proved effective.
This was used in conjunction
with spreading quicklime
on the floors.
Quicklime is a caustic
calcium oxide and it was used
to raise the cave's Ph and
dehydrate the microorganisms.
Here we see a poultice
containing the fungicide being
used directly over the artwork.
You'll be comforted to know
that a literature search assured
the participants this approach
would prove harmless
to the rock art.
A second example of mold
getting its signals crossed due
to an environmental
imbalance occurred
after Hurricane Katrina in 2005.
I visited Biloxi Public Library
with my friend Gary Frost
where we found some of the
windows broken in the library
so there was airflow
inside the building
and there were pine
needles on the floor
about a foot and a half deep.
It was surreal to walk on it,
it's like walking on mattresses.
So, we're padding lightly
inside of the library,
which in fact showed no visible
signs of mold three weeks
after the storm, though
it was summertime,
it was really hot, very humid.
Eventually the building would
be lost to mold however.
We did find, however, in the
basement a glass exhibit case
that did not get directly
wet, was raised up,
but it's a closed
glass, locked glass case
and it contains these baskets
that are completely covered
in gray mold, that gray is
not the way the baskets looked
before the mold this is after.
The rare book room which was
kind of a sequestered space
in the building had map drawers
that were when you pulled them
out the mold was thriving.
And this is an interesting
one okay,
inside of a storage cabinet
Gary found this Tyvek envelope
that was molding badly,
but inside the same storage
cabinet there were paper
envelopes with similar books
in them in the same drawer
that were not molding.
The Tyvek envelope made the
book look like that right,
what does that tell us, do
you think I'm leading you?
I'm glad you're a
bunch of smart folks.
So, I'd like to look at some
preventive concepts right,
to balance that out
a little bit.
So, here let's start with
the great pyramid of Khufu.
This is the oldest and
largest of the three pyramids
in the Giza pyramid complex
and it's also the oldest
of the seven wonders
of the ancient world
and the only one still
remaining largely intact.
A unique feature
of this pyramid is
that the king's burial
chamber is cross-ventilated.
Here we can see in the image
air vents that penetrate
from the pyramid's north and
south faces and all the way
into the king's burial chamber.
The queen's chamber also has air
vents and while they're longer
than the vents for the king's
burial chamber they were
never completed.
So, they're 20 feet short
of reaching the outside
of the pyramid interesting.
But that room was
never used so maybe
that explains why they didn't
bother to complete them
or they're waiting you know.
The air vents into the king's
chamber supply a fresh flow
of air in the otherwise
stagnant space.
but they're not straight
channels.
The northern air duct for
instance, measures 5 by 7 inches
and begins as a dome-shaped vent
that penetrates the granite
wall horizontally for 6 inches,
changes shape to an
oval that angles upward
for another 8 inches, and
then changes shape again
to a rectangle that
passes through 160 feet
of granite masonry to the
exterior of the pyramid.
Additionally, with each
shape shift the duct changes
direction, so it first heads due
south, then it heads southwest
and then further southwest.
So, these air ducts that's the
actual, it's a picture it's hard
to make it out until
you focus on it right,
but that's a picture of the
air duct that I just described
where it begins in
the king's chamber.
So these, you know, realize
how intentional this is.
You had to cut the ducts
in the granite blocks before
you laid them in place.
This is all preliminary to
actually setting these stones.
So, one might argue that this
natural cross-ventilation was
needed to provide fresh air
during the pharaoh's funeral
rites which were performed
by porch light inside
the core of the pyramid.
It's also a possibility, this is
what I'm proposing we consider
you conservation types,
that this is a thoughtful
architectural feature designed
to provide appropriate
environmental storage conditions
for the ages.
Can we have a vote, can
we have a show of hands?
So, there are other more recent
examples, let me show you.
This is a classic
18th-century cedar hope chest,
notice it's raised off
the floor and the lid
which is you know cut
from wood is not airtight,
so we get airflow below it
and through that little gap
in the lip of the cover.
This effectively promotes
slow, steady ventilation
and a stable environment,
it's in the human comfort zone
at the foot of the bed.
This is a 19th-century
iron bookshelf
that has a screen
grate at the bottom
and it promotes air circulation
behind and around the books.
This is one from the US
Department of Agriculture,
freshly picked and shelled high
moisture corn can present a mold
problem in storage.
The alternative is
and this is from 1969,
is to use unheated outside
air forced through a grate
at the bottom of the storage
container, which then filters
up through the top of the unit,
so airflow equals no mold,
long-term grain storage.
Elementary schools closed for
the summer lock all the doors
and windows and they're trying
to prevent vandalism makes
sense except this can lead
to a mold outbreak by the
time they come back to open
up the building in the fall.
So, a way to prevent a mold
bloom could be as simple
as opening up the windows a
crack and allowing the building
to breathe like a cave.
But I think the most
telling example is
that I am breathing
600,000 mold spores an hour
and I'm not breaking
out in mold.
Those conidia are
certainly landing in a warm,
dark and humid environment
right.
But I think in each of these
examples we can see the
usefulness or the
necessity of allowing airflow
to prevent mold growth right,
what if we could actually
communicate with it, maybe not.
But there are triggers for mold
events and that's what we have
to wrap our head around.
When do we see it coming
right, when is it a possibility
that we're going to actually
have this thing happen
because the moment
before it's happened
like the Biloxi public library
things are good and eventually
that building was torn down.
So, ways that we can deal with
it include conservation heating,
dehumidification and
adaptive ventilation.
Heating right, it's a kind
of counterintuitive thing,
in the summertime and Biloxi
would we actually turn
up the heat, but warm air holds
more moisture than cold air
so there's an option
in some circumstances.
But alternatively, the one
I like the most is desiccant
or refrigerant dehumidification,
which can effectively lower the
relative humidity inside great
big buildings to 25%
and rapidly dries
out everything, everything.
Adaptive ventilation promotes
drying, so air passing
over a wet surface
retains water.
According to a 2004
study by Tim Padfield,
moving air becomes completely
saturated when it passes
over wet material
regardless of the air's speed.
So, airflow changes surface
tension causing evaporation
that can prevent
fungal growth in caves,
elementary schools
and in my lungs.
Tyvek envelopes, sealed
glass exhibit cases,
and locked doors intended
to protect rare books prevent
airflow that can readily lead
to an environmental imbalance.
As noted by Monty Python and
now I'm quoting the best,
the difference between
the living and the dead is
so tenuous that it can
be easily mistaken.
This is an essential
truth for mold.
In situations where there's
no ready access to electricity
as with this Historical Society
in rural Mississippi flooded
during Hurricane Katrina,
the only option may be to
simply open the windows right,
it makes sense.
There are conditions where we
would find that very difficult,
but in theory this will
change the environment inside
and it might help.
The problem in this particular
case was the curators were more
concerned about vandals
than they were about mold
and so they kept shutting
the windows, they would leave
and they would shut the windows.
Sterilization is a technical
option when we're dealing
with mold and so it
should be discussed,
but we should not
use it casually.
The caption on this cartoon
reads wanting his picnic
with Gwen to be perfect Hal made
sure they would not be bothered
by ants.
Sterilization is expensive, it
can damage cultural property,
but when flooding
involves sewage
or other biological human risks
it may be necessary to consider.
So, let me touch on it
briefly, due diligence right.
The image of a commercial,
this image of a commercial
ethylene oxide chamber was
provided by Sterigenics.
The effectiveness of ethylene
oxide sterilization is dependent
on load density,
gas concentration,
steam inject, and
the cycle time.
Each of these factors have to
be correctly applied in order
for the sterilization
process to be effective.
Ethylene oxide is non-damaging
to paper as verified
in the 1960's by
Francois [inaudible].
This is a schematic of a
gamma radiation chamber
that was also provided
by Sterigenics.
You can see that it's a
simple system actually,
it's a lead shell with a core
of nuclear material inside.
And the stuff that you need
to sterilize passes by that.
Gamma radiation sterilization
is a simpler process
than ethylene oxide.
The density of the product
determines the cycle time
and the dosage required
in the radiator.
The validation process
is shorter,
so it may cost less
than ethylene oxide.
However, gamma radiation
cleaves covalent bonds,
which makes it absolutely
damaging
to cultural property,
just a heads up.
At the end of the
day killing mold
by sterilization is a little
like bringing pesticides
to a picnic however.
Whether mold is dead or merely
inactive due to the lack
of moisture it's
the same effect,
it doesn't really matter.
Inactive mold stops
consuming organic material
and it desiccates.
It could do no further harm
if environmental conditions
prevent its recurrence
and the desiccated mold can
be vacuumed up with a HEPA vac
or it can just simply
be brushed away.
And you should do this
outside with the wind coming
over your shoulder so you
don't actually get a face full
of desiccated mold.
So, thank you for that detour,
back on the point of the talk.
I got back to the United States
after my trip to Georgia,
a wonderful place
you should visit,
it really was great,
I loved it actually.
And I wrote a final
report defining the source
of the mold problem and
providing the library
with a protocol for
recovery of its rare books.
In summary, you know,
we can summarize,
in our easy armchairs
we can summarize.
The way to deal with
this problem in Georgia
in my estimation and
that of colleagues was
that the free water must be
eliminated in the building
and to do that we would
need to construct a gallery
on three sides of the
building to provide a barrier
between the groundwater
and the basement walls.
We would need to repair the
culinary water pipes in the core
of the building and realize
those are running in the walls,
that may be really difficult.
And we decided we really needed
to add downspouts to be able
to move the rainwater away
from the base of the building.
Everything we could do
to eliminate water
into the building.
The mold spores need to be
prevented from spreading
into the rest of the building
while we're trying to deal
with these really,
really moldy rooms.
So those rooms need to
be positively ventilated,
that's kind of a trick because
they're down in a subbasement.
But what we need to
do is exhaust the air
from the room while we're
drying it through HEPA filters
and exhausted to the outside,
not through the building
or get the hoses to go
through the building.
So, it's a little
complicated, it's the kind
of equipment we wouldn't
have lying around.
But we could bring equipment
in and I talked to people
who are willing to do it.
So next, the storage rooms
needed to be dehumidified
and that would dehydrate
the mold
and once it was dehydrated
it would be inactive
and so the desiccated mold
could be cleaned simply enough
by HEPA vacuuming it up, we
could just HEPA vac up the mold
and on the books on the
walls on the shelves.
Whether we did the books in
the same room or not was open
to discussion, but we could
even start there just vacuuming
them up.
And then the walls
and the shelves needed
to be washed with
soap and water.
That was from the CDC
and I was fascinated
because they're not talking
about the use of chlorine
at all, soap and water.
Because in fact adding chlorine
to the environment
might bother people
who have already got
sensitivities going on because
of all that mold and
of course all this has
to be done wearing personal
protective equipment.
And afterwards we need to
judiciously aerate the rooms
and the building, find
a way to create airflow.
But now a year later I am sorry
to report mold is
still on the books.
I've had a report from Georgia
that they had some
success repairing that pipe
out on the street and so maybe
that source of water is gone,
but I think the water inside
the building is still a
major problem.
I was actually really, I'm
still really disappointed
with this outcome and
maybe that's the way I want
to leave this talk this
morning or this afternoon,
it's still morning where I live.
If we come from out of
country and offer up solutions
that seem simple enough,
seem reasonable it doesn't mean
they're actually affordable,
it doesn't mean that they're
within the scope of the kind
of work people can
actually take on
or that they meet the
priorities of the people.
And I don't know what those are,
but I don't think they're books.
And this is a historic
building that's being preserved
by just leaving it in spaces.
They've protected it in
that it's identified as such
in this whole region of town,
including this next slide
behind Marie, those are supports
for a historic part of town,
18th and 19th century buildings
that they're preventing from
falling in by having put braces
in place, but there's no
money for repairing them.
So, at this point in
the history of Tbilisi
and of Georgia there are
bigger issues then dealing
with some things like
cultural property.
And so, we have to delay our
ambition to see a solution,
it would make me happy, it would
make her happy, and I don't know
when it's going to happen.
I'd like to thank a
whole bunch of people,
the people in Georgia, people
of the CDC, Kirk Lively,
the bunch of folks at Belfor,
for people at Sterigenics.
And Jeff David who actually
decorated this paper,
that's a splatter design on
paper that's not actually mold,
well you knew that right.
So, I'll leave it with
that, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Fenella France: Do we
have questions for Randy?
I'm actually going to
ask Randy for the benefit
of our people offsite to repeat
and rephrase the question.
>> Randy Silverman: Thank you.
>> Fenella France:
Any questions?
>> Randy Silverman: Oh, I can
rephrase it, so I'll tell lies.
Now is my chance,
I'm in Washington.
Oh wait, that was not
nice sorry, sorry.
Who's got a question?
Yes.
>> Randy, just for clarification
the galleries were not built
for this [inaudible]?
>> Randy Silverman:
Correct, we were not able
to build the galleries, at least
to this point they
have not built.
>> I imagine that would be
pretty expensive to undertake?
>> Randy Silverman: Every --
so, the is you know
would it be prohibitive
because it's expensive.
It's a big building,
but honestly the beauty
of the idea was that
it was digging a hole
and that manual labor or
a backhoe was within scope
of the kinds of things
people could imagine doing.
Bringing dehumidifiers was not
necessarily and so there's sort
of you know levels of buy-in,
but it didn't seem strange
to the local people,
to the architect
and to the preservation
architect to be able to dig
that gallery, and they've
done other similar projects.
I think, however, at this
particular moment in the history
of Georgia it's not as possible
as it might've been
10 years ago,
so I think it's actually the
time at which this is occurring.
Does that help?
>> Yes.
>> Randy Silverman: Thank you.
Please Andrew.
>> So, is there some
impediment to moving the books
like it seems like the
building is the problem,
so you have moldy books,
the books could be moved
to another location, but
undoubtedly there's a reason
that this, I mean were not.
But it just seems
like [inaudible].
>> Randy Silverman: So, Andrew's
question for those of you
at home I'll try
and do a better job,
I'm a reporter on the scene.
Andrew suggests that
it would be reasonable
to move the moldy books to a
different space and clean them
up and keep the books there.
It's a good idea and let me say
that we talked about
it at length.
We actually identified a
different place in the building.
The problem with the building
itself is a lack of controls,
but the part that we
visited seemed to be dry,
but again they were locked rooms
right, a series of locked rooms.
But we talked about
actually putting a fume hood,
a new fume hood in this place
and using that as a staging area
and then keeping the books
in that part of the library.
There was a hesitation
to jump ahead
and not cure the mold problem
in the basement for fear
that it would not be cured and
that the building would remain
so unhealthy and that it
would affect the people.
But I think it's a
very real possibility
and I think the director
of the library really
wanted the books treated
because they're valuable books.
So, it's completely possible
to actually move the books
to a dry space, rehab the space
so that it would be safe to work
in to eliminate the mold,
and leave those rooms moldy.
But there is a hesitation
about whether they would then
just be forgotten as like moldy,
you know, and maybe the
CDC would then be happy
that they're growing,
they're still going nicely
as a study so.
Please.
>> These are [inaudible],
not indigenous culture heritage
they were actively collected
and [inaudible].
Have they thought about
pragmatically going
through what they have, if they
had any, this is what they have,
cleaning up and selling some
to fund the work [inaudible]?
>> Randy Silverman:
That's interesting yeah.
We didn't really talk, I think
there's a desire to keep them
because of their value,
but I think the idea --
I will pass it along,
the idea of cleaning them
and selling them to be able
to clean the building
is interesting.
They're not indigenous
books, they are, you know,
they're I think of interest
because they are not in Georgian
or Russian, but actually
Latin books.
And I think it's a
very interesting idea
because there's a
real lack of money.
The other cultural problem is
that you know f A plus B does
not necessarily get us to see.
In effect, it might
be that if we figured
out that they were valuable
and started to sell them
that the money might not come
back to the library anyway,
that the priorities
are still greater.
And we don't know what they are,
they could be health issues,
they could be human
issues that you
and I would probably agree they
are the most important issues.
So, I think it's just a time
in the history of this project
that it's not particularly
going to work.
Yeah.
>> And a related note.
>> Randy Silverman: Yes.
>> You said they were
originally in Germany,
do you know anything
[inaudible]?
>> Randy Silverman: I don't
I actually was told Germany
as a generic, I tried
to press a little bit
and I didn't get any
information about that.
I don't know which library they
were dealing with or which group
of people, you know,
were the Germans,
but the Germans were very
generous in trying to deal
with the problem but there
was a lot of difficulty.
And so, there were
people getting involved.
What's been wonderful is I have
not met anybody who's aware
of this problem who
wasn't willing to you know,
give of themselves to try
and help make it better and.
>> I was just wondering
if [inaudible]?
>> Randy Silverman:
So, the question is
where were those original books,
where were they housed
in Germany.
I don't know that, I
don't know that sorry.
>> Fenella France: One
question from offsite.
Are there preservation
service programs in Georgia?
>> Randy Silverman: The question
from offsite is are there
preservation service programs
in Georgia.
The program is basically Menana,
this Georgian Blue Shield
is a very active group
and they've had a series of
disaster training workshops
that I'm aware of and they
are trying to coordinate,
but I don't know that
there's very much funding
to support these things.
I'm very proud of the
work that they've done.
And the kinds of
cultural property you know
when I show you these European
books it pales compared
to the Georgia books
I was shown,
I was shown some
astounding stuff,
amazing things, really gorgeous.
There's great cultural
property there to be cared for
and people are concerned.
I saw another hand, where?
>> This just on one of
the slides [inaudible]?
>> Randy Silverman:
A series of stamps.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Stadsbibliotek was identified
as maybe what the stamp
said inside the book.
I've actually not
looked closely,
but I think that's true.
So, you know, the Germans tried
to help make the problem better,
they really did and I think
they would've been happy
to take the books back at one
point, but too much red tape.
Yasmine.
>> You went into the space also,
how do the library
staff access the space,
do they use the books,
what is [inaudible]?
>> Randy Silverman:
So, the question
from Yasmine is what does
the library staff do relative
to going in and out
of that space
and how are they using
the books currently.
I was shocked to
see some people,
I mean I made it a big part of
my report I didn't note this.
But anyone going in there,
I mean it's the most severe
mold outbreak I've seen
and anyone going in there needs
to have personal
protection equipment.
But the person with the
key for instance thought
that was hooey she didn't care,
it was like a ridiculous
you know Western attitude,
what was I bringing to the
problem, what was I thinking.
I was you know obviously and
she did wander in and out
of it, I mean and others.
So, I know there are people
who react differently to mold
and she was hardy,
there's no question.
There are people in the
library, so the answer
to the book question,
they're not using the books
and there's a little effort
to vacuum off the mold
and so we went through that
protocol, but it's very slow.
These are 80,000 books,
so it's a slow process
and they were trying to
vacuum every single page.
I suggested we focus just
on the exterior mold
and let it be enough.
It's a question you
know what's enough.
But the people in the library
is a really interesting question
because one person who was
doing digital scanning got sick
and so he went to the doctor
and the doctor said you
have a respiratory thing,
take this whatever
this was, and don't do
that work for three weeks.
And so, he came back to work,
but kind of was not working
and I said well do I mind
if I use you as an example
to plead the case that there
are health problems here
and he said oh that'll be fine.
And then he thought
about it overnight
and he said tomorrow said no
way, don't do that because
and he left it at that.
But others explained to me
that if you put your job
in jeopardy you might
never get another job
and that there were young
people caring for their parents
and their parents at
home were in their 40's
and they were essentially
retired
out because there
were limited jobs.
So, people are not willing to
openly say we have a problem
because there's consequences so.
>> Fenella France: We have
a couple more questions
from offsite, they're
quite long ones.
Do you want to speak?
>> Fenella France: Let me just.
>> Randy Silverman:
Yeah, just say it.
>> Fenella France:
So, one question is,
would there be a problem
from a health standpoint
for future access
of the collection post-mold
cleaning due to the scale
of the problems, so it's
a wee bit supposition.
>> Randy Silverman: Yes, good
for you, that's a great question
and it enters in an area that we
don't really know definitively
how to define.
For cost reasons
it's fair to assume
that just removing the mold on
the books is probably the extent
of the treatment that
would be possible.
One of the hesitations
to doing that
and then putting the books
back in the storage place
in the building is it's maybe
not environmentally dry enough
for us to get away with
just having vacuumed it off.
But we could monitor them and
we could monitor the Rh in rooms
that they chose to
house them in.
And if things were improved
or kept to a minimum,
basically the number we think of
is below 65% relative humidity,
we're probably going
to be all right.
But the question you know
if you're probing me to say
if a person was really sensitive
to molds and the people who are
for instance have just had
children, they've given birth,
they have immune deficiency
problems, they've had surgery,
they have AIDS, that category of
person tends to get a reaction
to mold more easily than say me.
And that being the case, it
would be difficult to say
that for everyone just having
vacuumed off the mold will
be enough.
I think so, however, I feel
pretty good about that saying
that would be a solution in
most cases, but I'd really
like to see ventilation, outdoor
air coming into a building
that had this kind of problem.
I was involved, if I could
just say, I was involved
in a different disaster in 1997
at Colorado State University
and because of that
very thing every book
that was damaged, it
was 450,000 books.
Got a little slip inside it that
said this is a copy of a book
that was in that flood and
so it's like a heads up.
This space because it was an
entire floor of the building,
this space in theory is maybe
different and maybe you should.
I suggested to the university it
would be wise to just post that.
>> Fenella France:
One more [inaudible].
>> Randy Silverman: Sure.
>> Fenella France: What
was the interest or buy-in
for the community to
support the stabilization
and conservation of
the books on site?
>> Randy Silverman: I don't
think the community generally
knows about this
book collection,
so I don't know what the
status of that information is.
But when I told people of
course everybody is sympathetic
to the idea that we
should fix this problem.
But I don't think it was widely
known that there are books
and certainly not
in that condition.
And I would think for instance
when the Center for Disease
and Health from Georgia
got involved
that they would've been kind of
shocked by things and the fact
that they weren't makes me think
there's a different standard
than I'm aware of at play.
One and two good.
Hi, hi Nora.
>> Hi, could you tell us
how you got CDC involved
and the [inaudible]?
>> Randy Silverman: It's
a wonderful question,
so Nora [inaudible] asked
when did I get the CDC
involved, how smart am I.
The question actually is it's
a really interesting answer.
I left Georgia on a plane
like some, you know,
five in the morning
kind of flight
out of you know small countries
and I was so frustrated,
I knew we didn't quite get
there and I was desperate.
And so, I was talking
to my seatmate,
a woman sat down one seat
over and we talked all the way
to Germany who was from the CDC.
You know there is
goodness and mercy
in the world, but it's hiding.
But she sat down
and she connected,
I told her how desperate
the situation was
and she connected me with people
in Atlanta who connected me
with specialists in West
Virginia who deal with mold.
And so, it was by
virtue of serendipity,
a great research tool.
Andrew.
>> Yeah, so I'm thinking
now about the ventilation
and the shafts to
the king's tomb and.
>> Randy Silverman:
There you go.
>> And clearly that
was planned out ahead
of time you know for
whatever reasons.
Are there anyone that you know
of [inaudible] planning
these kinds of things
into future building
designs for libraries,
for cultural heritage
divisions to say let's put
in an architectural gallery,
let's put in an [inaudible]
system that we can hook
up to any interior space
in the building as we need
to do this kind of thing?
>> Randy Silverman: So.
Andrew is asking for
those of you at home,
you know the king's
ventilation shafts,
the pyramidal ventilation
shafts is such an ideal use
of existing technology that
it leaves me stunned frankly.
And you're observing
that there's a real merit
in capturing ideas like
that and applying them
in the present day is
absolutely a theme I have going
in the back of my head.
What do we know that
we've forgotten right,
what as a culture have we like
eliminated for whatever reason
and simply overlooked
at this point.
Because when I found
those shafts just looking
through literature I was
shocked, it was like look
at what they thought
of back then.
And Andrew asked are thinking
about applying those
in modern buildings.
I don't know enough about
architecture, this is a --
I'm out of my depth,
but there are people,
especially planning
conservation environments
who know an awful
lot about this.
But what you're leading
to is a very key point
and then I probably
have to wrap up.
But the idea that if
we build buildings
that are hermetically sealed
because we can do HVAC
control that's great as long
as it's working and the day
that it's not working we don't
have a second option right.
It's a completely sealed system
on purpose, which puts us
at a huge disadvantage and or
when there's something wrong
in the building, it's just
a little out of whack.
Getting to a place that we
could ventilate the book storage
in Georgia was going to be
difficult, we would have
to ventilate upstairs and out.
You'd have to have a mile of the
tubing and or cut a hole right
through the wall, which I
doubt they were interested
in doing below-grade.
So, when we build modern
buildings are we thinking
this way.
I think there's a group
of people who are aware
of this stuff, but we should be
harvesting and I'll leave this
at the last note, we should
be harvesting the bright ideas
in every way that we can and
some of them are ancient.
And to ignore these old ideas
because they're outdated is
not really paying attention.
When we get into a fix and
we're desperate for an answer,
when we start clutching
at straws and we come
across something like this we
should be talking to each other,
we should be harvesting
these ideas because it's not
out of its own time now, it's
still time for us to come
up with alternatives
and variations
on the way we're
approaching things.
>> Can I ask a final question?
>> Randy Silverman: Yes, I
would love one more question.
>> Just to return to
the university library.
Obviously, they're operating
on a different reality,
but despite that were there
any lessons learned for you
that you could share with us?
If you had to do it again, would
you do anything differently
and [inaudible] forward
to the next time
or are you [inaudible]?
You know there are going to be
limitations on their reality.
>> Randy Silverman: Mary Oi
[phonetic] just asked the
million-dollar question,
what did I learn.
I approached the problem with a
sense of being able to solve it.
I was so convinced the answer
was intellectually within grasp
and I was so knocked off center
by my inability to do that.
And the thing I would
like to share
with you is we can
know how to fix it
and we can still not
be able to fix it.
It's a terrible position to
be in, it's really terrible
and you know what it's like
a combination of things.
But in answer to your question,
I failed pure and simple.
I don't know that I could
have won, I don't know how.
I begged the people on
the ground you know six
and eight months later to tell
me how I could've done better
and they said you did fine,
you know, what are they going
to say, they're going
to insult me
and tell me what an
idiot I am, I doubt it.
But I have to say I
think they were sincere
and I think all we
can do is try,
I think the best
we can do is try.
And the idea of harvesting
old ideas that still are valid
or looking more carefully
at things
that we have rejected
along the way
so that I can bring
a cheap answer.
The answer was cheap, if I
could have just found a way
to do it for free.
I was conning people into, you
know, goading people into coming
for nothing if they would just
show up on site and ventilate
that room appropriately so
it wasn't a health risk,
I had a man committed to doing
several trips if he had to,
to work for nothing
to make this better,
and there was not
money to do that.
So unfortunately, I'm actually
having to swallow the raw pill
that it's not possible in
every case to fix these things
and we all live with failures
in little ways all of the time,
it's humbling, it's frustrating,
and we can do better.
I would hate to say, to leave
this on a negative note,
but optimism is not necessarily
going to be able to fix it.
So, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit
us at LOC.gov.